hey this is the mild adventures of Fred
Stoller I'm Fred Stoller I'm not
starting with the silly theme thing with
my mother because with continuing part
two nor MacDonald called up we already
had Felipe Esparza Amber Tozer of course
and norm is just cracking us up with
crazy stories people he knew from
stand-up just have everything so if if
you don't listen to part one maybe go
back to that if you love all things norm
as this is all things comedy podcasts so
we're just continuing it thank you
these razors are alive no way yeah that
it looks like what how's the listing
decision release judge podcast can you
call in you okay I thought no I'm on his
podcast but can you write now how does
Keith know we're doing a podcast did you
put it up
could you call in and wait a minute how
did it had his keep know you were on the
pot it was just a lucky accident oh so
he calls you so so norm I I want to come
clean about something
yeah hello yeah Keith how did you know
what norm was calling my podcast
well you just call him alright I just
pulled norm to listen a happy birthday
because it's tomorrow they told me to
call you guys Wow happy birth Wow see
you call norm not just text and this is
Wow you're you're in good company thank
you for coming to my book event Keith's
hilarious thank you thank you
so I tweeted the thing you asked me to
retweet this is going to get a lot of
people
and especially you know so um anything
you want to say Keith oh no I was just
calling to norms that call see this is
my yeah what I call you on your birthday
do Fred
how do you know when my birthday is oh
you could just google it right yeah
that's what women do and then they
dumped me when they see my age and so
you uh now we talked about you have you
said you have no empathy huh I do but
they say people with Asperger's don't
have that bippy and you have Asperger's
if you if you prove you have empathy can
you get the the label the diagnosis
rescinded some people what you kind of
lack of empathy but still have empathy
yeah I like you could have you could see
there have empathy for other people huh
but when I met you you said your example
was your friend said he could hurt his
ankle and you wouldn't care what did
your friend said he once hurt his ankle
and you didn't care just hurt if I'm
really close with them I care but it's
like if it's just some dude and it's
always about ankles I'm norms trying to
call in again amber do you have to go
because it's I have to go soon okay but
will keep will this is very special
because I look I have to confess the
Norma - yeah I'm so norm I have I have
something I want to come clean about
norm Asbergers
you should hope in within physics or
faith as burgers after every joke so I
was walking the street as the burgers
my mom died as burgers hey I don't give
a [ __ ] about other people as burgers
burger Keith you find Donald Trump is
like a gift comedic Lee you know it
normally stud what's that
is that normal Keith honey me norm okay
don't worry about Keith ringing yeah
well norm happy birthday all right I
want a quick norm confession okay cuz
hey big man
in my book I said you used to throw
rackets and curse and I have to say I
did too I left that out I want it I
think it's amber and I'm not just doing
this to include amber that's my
self-hatred
I used to curse in throw rackets because
I hated myself of being a loser and
missing shots and stuff but I remember
playing maybe I was playing like rate up
to show time and then everyone left to
go to the show and I was playing with
that tennis club that was repossessed no
no I was right before showtime me you
and Arnie were playing tennis and I said
Norman we're getting sweated up we're
about to do your show you go I don't
give a [ __ ]
norm doesn't Erica don't show and then
when I went the guy wasn't gonna let me
in and I'm like no I have a show he's
like no you don't know you were more to
playing tennis I already been on two
years only there's a show called the
norm show it's right between here and
friends it was you remember that
basketball be George Cloney playing with
her goal it was like on the Warner
Brothers lot there's
yeah they're a really good bass but like
all the handsome guys we're diggin
athletic also like really David or Kent
would play but I remember when so when
we play tennis yeah I would throw the
racket a lot and and get very frustrated
one time I got married it was a very
high tone tennis club I don't think we
even wore flights or anything so that I
think we being Jean sometimes oh yeah
remember Craig Ferguson or Craig Kilburn
one of them I forgot which one was going
hey look at Fred playing in jeans when
we bumped into him you know hey yes he
and I was playing in jeans he goes hey
great pants you know didn't that correct
he was like he was like a Ted Baxter
kind of guy but I remember yeah so a
Felipe in amber and Mike I looked
include people and mmm there used to be
these Sunday tournaments where this guy
named um I forgot what his Stewart would
do you have these like different
divisions and he would take all the
money and whoever wins in a division
gets to get a lesson from him so I won
and he just had me like doing push-ups
and running around yes and that was what
I wanted right right well I think Kenny
creme is gonna reopen the case because
he's gonna pro no no I'm just kidding he
tried to reopen
I'm just making a joke but it proved
that I lied about I did not care yeah I
didn't I didn't I didn't I didn't come
with our idea for you to do Asperger's
actually ever joke on you know what
Felipe Esparza is Keith I do was sober I
don't know personally but I know he
thought I could stroke to go Asperger's
no like that comedian ham
their butts the ass burning so no why do
we get so tell him again what to called
SoundCloud he sound exchange is where
every comedian can look for their money
from every time they played your album
on a radio station to promote your show
every turn a butcher your comedy on I'm
serious
Sony's changed looks for your bits and
they give you a list of when they played
it what time they played it what bits
were bought and all that stuff
so no one's got a lot of money coming -
yes they do
Wow and also Felipe is a great person
for getting the word out my favorite
line when you were judging Last Comic
Standing it was this guy - killed anyone
he that was material free yes he killed
that was material free it's just the guy
just being attractive and jumping a
latino guy he killed but there was no
material you just is charming and it's
like that a new show like with Neil
Patrick Harris is called like the most
fun and like its ever it's not funny
this is fun I get fun so they just
ripped all the pretense out of it God
the fun show are you gonna go on that
thing there used to be shows in the 50s
where actors would do charades with each
other you know as a made a big comeback
this idea of how much Jane Lynch of
watching famous people have each other
and those games people play the and then
comedic now that he's just proving
they're horribly unfunny like they
should never you know Jason Alexander's
never make a performance outside of
science
there's each other now let me at you
when you say that norm you know it's
interesting when I was in the comedy
boom of the 80s when there's a million
comedy clubs they didn't have what they
have now comedic actors just going
onstage and going hey you remember and
they did sing songs some sketch shows
they were in they're not stand-ups but
they go hey remember when I was on
Newsradio hey and they applauded no you
never saw Isaac from The Love Boat host
DB T or anything like that no yeah
that's a good point in the 70s 80s Isaac
would have done clubs go hey let's do it
together hey Love Boat and remember this
episode well like III don't like that
personally because like me and you are
like trained comics I don't like to see
what a person takes work from trained
comics that are just I mean
personalities my act calls true but you
know presentational acts or well what do
you what would you call it like you know
when you go to see a donkey that you saw
there just got to see the person I don't
care
well I just want to take a picture with
him after this I know that whenever
people like people like when they when
they book these mean sensations that are
so funny for fifteen seconds
you know they have to do 45 minutes I
remember the only guy that everyone
david alan grier yes there was no mark
price yes he was
I remember when he cries in a Nirvana
video no he was Skippy on family ties oh
and I remember he had the MC say he's
only 25 so then when I went up I had I
had the MC say he's only 35 I was only
35 at the time like so he would just go
hey me and Mallory may would you like to
see me and Mallory get it on but then 35
years later he's still doing it actually
the job we did to get a Philippe the guy
who picked me up at the airport said
they had mark price and they had todd
bridges the week before together
so Todd brother truTV tour yet so Todd
bridges to stand up and he probably gets
up there who'd think I was the only
survivor a guy of the uh you know of the
facts of life hey you didn't think you'd
see me here probably told jokes like
that right ass bother guys I guess it's
not unreasonable to expect it you know
but like I always just thought of myself
as a stand-up comedian but then when I
go on the road they'd yell up stuff from
SNL you know because you know not
unfairly that's what they came to see
and I don't know what they thought I'd
do the guys that are actually comedians
just tell long stories but when they
were at SNL well they recreate from
Chris Patten just does like remember
when I did y know or whatever Jimbo and
he does it you know yeah Evans saying
Chris but I know he yeah he started as
an act from scratch because he used to
go out with like four other comedians
you know like real stand-ups and he
would just end this you know you know I
never thought I mean even great badges I
imagine they'd be very funny on stage
with his physical stuff you know there
was a guy on Last Comic Standing it was
physical and I remember he wrote it but
I really liked the guy I don't know if
you guys I did see him in the big nose
he fell down like Peter Pan counseling
super like Kramer stuff and and the
other two judges were like Nash not a
straight stand up I was like I'm tired
of straight stand-ups I've just seen
been an 80 of them in a row you know
like why don't I push this guy through
because they're so surprising he wears a
suit you know a full button suit and
then he does like insane Jim Carrey kind
of physical comedy
but anyway so ever he is I like to I
can't remember his name unfortunately no
I I did see some of them yeah I would
plug out give him a plug you'd give him
a plug you gave David Spade I saw a plug
of his book on a tweet right Keith yeah
I I did an event
oh no I saw you tweet I did my event and
Keith register and his friend were the
only one that came in Orange County you
sent me a tweet that was in fury it
sounded like a fury
oh just so depressing you go there and
it's going oh my god whatever but it's
it's as they say it's it's all hey hey
norm thanks for talking about football
what's that from
thanks a lot to talk about football I
just remember things you he laughs that
I think you might have been rich eyes
and it was no I can't remember guys
there was the other guy on SportsCenter
yeah yet the first interview of OJ
Simpson and I just asked about the
murder for 30 minutes and our champion
sarcastic said yeah it takes a lot place
we're talking about football
tweeting football this year I don't know
you know people get angry at me so I I
stopped for a while usually I think my
tweeting is sort of OCD I started doing
it in real time with sporting events and
then I couldn't stop yeah Felipe is this
fun talking to norm you met up yes I
have OCD I have stuff with a year
looking at envelopes and and having I've
reopened envelopes thinking I didn't
sign it or 33 times I've done things
like that yeah I'm on the road it takes
me so long to leave the room because I'm
always what I believe going to the
airport you know and you know sometimes
I try to get the other comic to
double-check it I was so fearful that
I've left something behind even though I
have so little to to leave well let you
leave there you guys I was on the road
Felipe intact yes she'll amber just left
I was just yeah yeah she's an Amber
Alert she she that this is a special yes
I was just at the I was at the Denver
Comedy Works
Denver laughs yeah that's a great closet
there yes the downtown one with the new
comedy condo Montana yes never the
brand-new comedy condo a loft - like
2,800 square feet
yes oh so they have condos for both yeah
I remember when I stayed in the comedy
condo back in when they were answering
machines you see I stayed in this guy's
place in Philly in his apartment then
you did the phone would ring
welcome to bananas please leave your
reservation you know everything leave it
for two Jerry party of three you know
old I'm trying to sleep all day that the
phone is ringing the answer machine
because you stay at the guy's house one
now he had a room but yeah I remember
yeah yeah
- Sun was a place that laughs comedy
comedy cafe where you stood there in the
other comic the headliner was still
there yes yes I did I did this one where
you know I'm in a comedy yes burger I I
mean you know I'm in the room and and
then I I remember I I wanted to get get
up and uh watch TV so I can deliver him
they had the comedian from the week
before still sleeping on the couch I
said you got a couple of times being in
a condo and a girl would show up at the
door and you have to tell her that you
know Chuck and left last week could she
be sad or some guys try to get the girl
you know I yeah I was supposed to open
for you norm
that would have been fun in what what
Texas City you know when when I was yes
when I was doing stand-up the first time
I wouldn't do well and you'd always get
some guy you know apologize and go and
this is Hicks this is Sacramento I get
you you know or they go these are Texans
they're idiots
I got your bum stories with
but then it was places like Boston or
San Francisco I go alright you can't
apologize you know you know for this
these idiot hayseeds you know you know
you know you don't have the one person
that goes I got you these guys are
idiots
you know like Felipe sells merch after
shows and and he does well I remember I
was trying to sell my book at flappers
after a show and the other comic was
getting mad like we're at a flea market
like pushing me off like elbowing me
shirts on the headliner move your buck
thank God that ik I shouldn't say but I
have a flappers story where I'm doing it
for free and and then there was a bad
night you know wasn't me so then the the
owner was so nervous because I'm low-key
she replaced me for some guy comes and
goes I'm here to replace Fred Stoller
he's still Loki and his act Greg horn is
pouring beer on his head flopping on
stage like a fish so she probably put
all that comic she probably looked
through unless the comics who's the most
not like Fred to make up for him oh the
guy that pours beer on his head and
spits at the audience Jake up for me
Greg hi that was very hot yeah ever
happen to you or they replace you in the
middle of the week yes I had a yeah the
middle of like singing theme song some
local commercials and dancing to my
prerogative and yes they did replace me
shorten my sad flip us yes there was a
black woman named there was a black
woman called just June she was bald I
know her yes and she would like sing you
better be good to me like Tina Turner
and run around the stage and or
applauding so there his Fred Stoller hey
you know you know I'm talking about just
you know I used to love norm about doing
stand-up but I used to love norm is when
I'd go on the road with people and we
walk around the mall and they go is this
middle-aged black bald lady walking
around with this never she Jewish guy
that it never adds up like well it's
like me Max Alexander and uncle dirty
this there's Abby's a guy and a nun a
middle-aged guy walking around malls
that's what I used to like like people
going you know cuz it doesn't always
look like like you're famous Felipe so
now if I walk around the mall legit ago
they'd stand ups but you know saying the
ink did you like that Felipe or am I
just yeah
enjoying something stupid yeah that's
the only time you know other comics
music see that a black dude a Chinese
guy and a white dude walking together no
it's not three samples
uncle dirty who you've mentioned before
Murr in the Rochester yeah accent uncle
journey for those of your listeners you
don't know was the comedian who when I
know this was 20 years ago he was 60
already or whatever and he would tell
stories but Lenny Bruce and George
Carlin and Redd Foxx but you never knew
if they were true he'd repeats noise a
lot too
and yeah and you'd go well he was back
that he was with them back there but
maybe he was a guy everyone ignored you
know didn't really know but anyways he
was headlining and I was middling and he
invited me in a room to smoke weed and I
don't smoke weed so it's just him
smoking weed and we were watching this
Tonight Show and George Carlin was on
this night show with Johnny Carson and
they're talking about the old days and
you know there's an Olive [ __ ] plays as
they played and then out of the blue
George song goes you you remember uncle
Turkey like just when I kept going and
so I got really sad that uncle dirty got
really happy yeah I was sad that we're
in this [ __ ] hotel room in Rochester
Felipe was inspired by stephen wright
and loki comics
that's is for right right philippe yeah
tell me when you tried the Comedy Store
and and Charles Fleischer came up to me
and I was talking to me so I got a new
this new CD you know I was like oh
that's going goes yeah he wanted I go
sure he was beheaded him it's $15
Felipe tell me when you met Stephen
right what would happen oh I was working
at um I'm working it I'd also um I've
seen the Elaine Boosler at Dodger
Stadium I have to work at Dodger Stadium
I'm making hot dogs for a long time and
I'm I saw Stephen Wright walk in he was
buying a hot dog and I was on the back
Dodger Stadium I had to cook and I just
I was a vendor I just saw some veneers
I saw programs but my last job was
making hot dogs and I saw Stephen Wright
walk in and nobody i working with knew
who the [ __ ] he was and I was excited do
you know that is that Stephen right then
his black a good man [ __ ] that nappy
hair [ __ ] I keep working and
then I'm so I said nobody knows this guy
used to tear the Oscar man and then I
went out and I went out there said
Stephen right you're my [ __ ] favorite
comedian man I saw you know your
comedian show with [ __ ] out Rodney
Dangerfield I started doing his bits and
then I stuck my hand out to shake his
hand and his hand he put it hand inside
of his hoodie and he shook it in my hand
with cloth that's exactly I was lying
through a you know a CVS and there
Stephen right did you whatever not
there's not so close together
I said pleasure to meet you the exact
same thing happened you know Howie
Mandel's whole entourage does the fist
bump thing he's got an entourage they
all did that shake you know Howie Mandel
won't shake your hand so he he smacks
your fists together yeah yeah and also
just his assistants did that too when
you shake their hand like what about
entourage meaning how he's entourage
call his team how he's team they all do
it too yeah yeah yeah
I don't know how he had a daughter well
he's got a God it's been his assistant
for 20 years good guy forgot his name
well he had a great comedian Oh perform
that I really love Dino's yeah yeah from
from your dome children yes yes once in
a while I'm still doing comedy in it to
me is hilarious I don't know yeah yeah
yeah these guys there you go hit that
guy would fit perfectly like in a show
you know well you know you said that
about that guy in your show you know oh
you'd be on a sitcom but it's not like
the old days where guys like Lou Grant
would be on a sitcom now funny character
actor looking them well Norman fells you
know I I'm in the wrong generation now
you gotta have spiky hair and be
good-looking and go dude you know they
mean the character actors you know don't
fit into my but he's a good-looking
weird guy ya know people go for you got
a great sitcom persona you should be in
when I go well I'm older and yeah it's
not that era of when they had shows like
Bob Newhart with mr. Carlin if mr.
Collins you know Alan yes he was the
voice of Barney or something and yes
Barney and he was in a way on the family
all that is a friend of Dick Van Dyke
when they'd show up in the army days
yeah they wouldn't have guys like bilko
on a show now like not good-looking
middle-aged guys but they were probably
only 30 and there's nothing wrong you
know I mean I was the perfect show to
showcase those perfect they don't have
character actors they said if did you
think you were gonna get a sitcom after
last comic standing Philippe
no why I just didn't I when I know I'm
when I I knew they were gonna hold me
back from working too they had a holding
deal for NBC for a year yeah and then I
I read for a pilot on Fox and I was a
runner up when they found out my
holding deal they went for the other guy
instead Oh God when they found out yet
holding oh because of the different
networks yeah different network well
with some of the comics Todd glass
always the first year
yeah the first year let's do that I won
let's come and standing I had a meeting
with Fox like two weeks later you won
first year I won them season seven
you came in seventh No season seven and
one less Comic Standing
no let's see on your show you don't know
you said you with with some of the
people you were against the first year
it wasn't a first year who was 70 when
Antoine Antoine with some people you
went against Philippe uh Roy woods
junior
Mike Kaplan Tommy John again and Mike
d'stefano oh he died yeah but Mike wants
the final I want oh yeah and the next
day my son's mom fall for child support
she became the last she became the last
baby mommas handy can you believe that
she saw you one last comic standing and
she filed for child support
yeah NBC told me someone file the next
day
that's like name that's like me and
Norman the Fantastic Four following your
claim I'm Johnny torch I should have
been your first pilot on a sitcom
instead of but they don't dis you too
aggressively try to create a
circumference oh yes I've had meetings
with eight I had a meetings with ABC
like two weeks ago we talked I meant
when you won like did you agree because
they give you the holding right yes I
had one yes I have one meeting with NBC
and I was it I'm at the casting director
and a lead person there now is this
really odd you think it would be it with
do you think it would be an NBC's
interest to have the winner of their
talent contests you know get a show and
surround them with writers and you know
if you surround anybody any good comic
with writers and actors I think they can
have a show as good I don't like those
roast but Seth MacFarlane did a joke
about someone
he hosts Last Comic Standing a show that
has launched no one because it sound
like American Idol by you
you gotta leap a you your wife told me
your success is putting your special on
Netflix and it just exploded yes I did
it was ok I did a special for for
Showtime right it's natural oh and hurt
nothing you know they mentioned it to me
and then two years later people were
like I saw you spent and suddenly
everyone thought it was because it was
on Netflix and then they took it off
Netflix no one's mentioned it again but
yeah Comedy Central no one thought they
premiered it yes all the other one over
special at midnight now needs to be at
10 o'clock
yeah no original shows and then they
premiere a comedian at midnight so some
people they like they produce this
special some you say I have one can I
put it on your network
did you see the live special by Brian
Regan no I was very good right yeah I
didn't even see Jeff Ross in prison yet
I mean he was so lucky to have to get to
do it live you know they don't do that a
lotta you'd be think that wouldn't have
been so new but I remember one time
David Brenner did it from Las Vegas and
the idea was using knew all the jokes
out of that days and then it was all
[ __ ] you know you know I sort of do
a little joke and I would lead to it
being long it had nothing to do with it
and and at the end of his special he he
he spent 15 minutes proposing to his
guru you know growing up I was you know
you were on a young comedian special and
I never got to be and then I was wanted
as the other special that was the big
thing you know but every time I asked
like by the time I got to that level
people
they go well we got like you know rich
Jenny's got still has a contract to do
six more and you know they decided guys
don't want ten special contracts like
Wow
Dennis Miller Richard Jenny and so they
go we got no no room you know but I
think it was a lie and then I thought no
comic could ever get big again you know
like after Kinnison there was a big long
stretch where where no comic got real
big and to like build her no I Sancho
Chris Rock right Dean cook I'm talking
about the last few years bill Bertha
less yeah well now it's kind of yeah
that's a lot a little a little bit of a
lot right because it's Lois bill burr
Amy Schumer and Dane Cook come in and
they come I mean bill burr will last
heard Dane Cook was the band from the
Laugh Factory
he caught a manager the C word and did
some screaming I built I own this club
it's such a cliche line like from a bad
movie I own this club I could take it
down you know but Jamie didn't didn't
hold on to him as a manager as soon as
that's what you know do I think he's
always been with Barry Katz from what I
know but yeah yeah but but you know
Jamie would give him like spots every
single night oh yeah laughs actor in
Dublin's he could have uh streets of
Dublin Dublin on Tuesday nights yeah
it's perfect for him because he could
jump on tables yeah you're dead except
for those kind of guys you know I mean I
think it's not handing in the middle of
a room with a mic that doesn't work but
if you're damn cook it works to
advantage but Chris D'Elia isn't he
charming the Titas Dublin's too right
you go from one to the other
he's like wait died two hours before
normal of 'he's brave comedians
Phillippi one sec
caps on its Twitter I will not apologize
but you know you know my new job is
apologized
what athlete layup tonight it's missed
some example my new job Norma making
extra money I sell tape masking the
first the person finds out about the
story about their father's death from a
joke I want to my new job is selling
masking tape to comedians when they put
over their mouths but you know when they
show this so far gone some comedians
come to me because could you believe
like I love I Wanda Sykes of books
called I said that yeah because they
need it for that post is they've tape
over their mouth goods you how can you
[ __ ] contain them
you better tape their mouths their arm
to me the most ballsy thing is when a
comedian gives the finger have you see
those pictures they don't give a [ __ ]
only point they give him the finger how
could they like Kid Rock it's like I
love Wanda Sykes book called I said that
you know like I always want to be at a
book store skin with her she didn't say
that
no she did not say that oh my god wait a
minute who could someone please sit her
down and you know when they dec end this
so in love with how brazen they think
they are like I [ __ ] say anything
hamburger hamburger this guy dick
Sargent came out of the closet he was
the guy that played the second Darren Rd
Reza huh so anyways he lived in Halle
was 80 and he came out of the closet you
know so I said oh I was I hope it
doesn't hurt his career because that was
the hippest joke ever and I can't
believe you made a joke about herb
Sargent he's some writer yeah this joke
I ever heard
and then it was like he was like sad
that it was big services some guy that
no one in the [ __ ] room would
possibly know did you Felipe did you see
all the evening and The Improv when they
used to have it on every night on A&E so
you're supposed to like when you do you
set you supposed to hug bud and it gives
you a game like of The Improv game but
he only had one and you'd have to give
it back makes it like you're getting a
game so then speaking of that what the
late Drake say there said little board
game play improv yes bumped that board
game must go I say like you know you
just hit Charles Fleischer move back
trees just got bumped by Dane Cook go
start your career but I remember when I
said The Laugh Factory I was stunned
because I was like oh these would be I
thought sleep in it when I went got to
LA it would be the greatest comics in
the world but I never get on stage
because of the Robin Williams and Garry
Shandling you know I didn't know and
instead it turns out like it's you know
it's just like a club in Ohio like they
have their favorite comics that they put
on all the time you know and at the time
at The Improv it was Scott I mean at the
last I drew Scott LaRose and this black
kid I can't remember his name James
Stevenson I got it I got it Schuyler
Rose story he there used to be a
blockbuster right by the Laugh Factory
and each parking spot said Kevin Costner
Mel Gibson Julia Roberts and one said
Scott LaRose you know like way like
stars you know reserved parking there's
all these you know Al Pacino and Scott
LaRose and the manager said yeah he made
a big stink like why don't you put my so
he fought to have his you know and like
a parking spot at Blockbuster along with
the other people he wrote a book and he
wrote for Dennis Miller Mike Dugan yes
Mike Dugan but but the Dugan this is a
guy that he used to because I want you
know I want to be a comedian because I'm
gonna want to be like a philosopher
that's why I love it the philosopher and
so what time he goes to me Fred you know
I'm big in England I go to England now
go okay that's good then I bump into him
in the street like hey Mike I hear you
really big in England because really is
that people been saying that if I'm just
kidding it was no are they talking about
me at The Improv and they saying that
and I can know why I'm just just saying
what you said come on now if there
aren't is someone saying that you know
these people that go to England Felipe
and that they become superstars like
rich hall you know II mean do they like
like and then I think the American
comics coming I mean they love all the
comics I hate America so if you go there
go and I [ __ ] Bush you know stupid [ __ ]
in America trying to invade Iraq you
know that's a good joke there's a guy
I'm not making fun of his Christian but
there's a guy called Brad Stein right
and he and he got to see clips cuz he
he's like Denis Leary but there's no
jokes yeah I'm a [ __ ] Christian and
conservative I'm [ __ ] saying that and
they applauded but there's no jokes
he's like pacing and Brad Stein look him
up on YouTube because he's Christian
Monaghan no no what did Brad Stein and
I'll tell you it what happened when I
was in I did one of those what's it
called NACA where you you do your act
and I bombed in Nebraska that's why I
don't call this gigs so the next day I'm
sitting in a booth like Lucy you know
and the psychiatrist and Charlie Brown
and no one is coming up to me I bombed
the night before and now all day I'm
sitting there not getting one job and
and Brad starting at a post he's high
energy he's animated he's crazy you know
something I would make up fooling around
but so yeah I got to send you links of
this guy cuz I was that this sort of
cynically that if you just said you're a
Christian you could play
giant you could open for joel osteen and
there's a big Christian comedy circuit
right yes there is
oh they do really well but this guy
again a lot of but this guy doesn't have
material like I said he just like Dennis
Larry screaming how you [ __ ] it auto
that's right I'm a conservative and a
Christian I say that then they applaud
it no that's his joke I'll send you the
links but you know activists or
you know I heard Johnny Carson say like
the most dangerous thing I guess so Mike
Dugan didn't hear this but the most
dangerous thing is when a comedian
becomes a philosopher well norm said he
got into send them to change people's
minds - what is this - I put shine a
truth on things you know we could change
things they did a documentary about
Scientology this is gonna shut down
Scientology no it's not no people are
gonna wait a minute it's an HBO
documentary I'm leaving you know these
things don't change things like people
think it does I don't know but yeah
especially like unchangeable things like
the things that Hicks would go after you
know oh yeah you saw the thing and I
love you big boy well everybody [ __ ]
knows they're evil like [ __ ] what do I
supposed to do about it I'm just a guy
with a lady that [ __ ] well I like
when people on Facebook go let's go
Dodgers like like the guy's gonna read
the day man look what they said come on
let's do better like they're gonna read
Jerry metal mixes a lot of people like a
lot of Latinos on my page it's on me I
heard I've noticed you haven't said [ __ ]
about Donald Trump Felipe what am I
supposed to say about him well you're
gonna like change ya people's minds like
I was gonna before I can't even vote
you should you should [ __ ] talk about
that I was gonna vote for I was gonna
vote for Trump but then someone put a
thing on Facebook and now I'm not I was
but I was again I was four guns but
someone put a thing about one of those
anti-gun videos and now I I see I know
what changes I mean to me like when you
said like jokingly the Trump was a gift
for comics yeah like I see it serve as
the opposite like it's so it's such a
big punching bag that it's impossible to
think yeah it's so ridiculous in the
first place he's so funny you know and
what he's know is that how do you make
it funnier like you know Sam Mike is
this okay we went so long no we're good
keep going okay okay well anything wanna
plug very hard to craft a joke about
what it's like when like an idiot that
doesn't understand that Trump already is
like when they did a roast for Charlie
Sheen or you know or Flavor Flav they're
ready you know whatever it's like wow
going after these guys how do you you
know you notice about your froze gnorm
no I'm urine Bob Saget's roast and then
then I like when Cloris Leachman gets up
and she goes norm I don't know who you
are and I wanted it but I couldn't
scream it out cuz I'm in home but she
did a guest spot on the norm show and
she's doing jokes like I have no idea
who this norm guy is but she was sort of
like when she was on that show sort of
crazy and then when she did the work
like all of a sudden like perfect you
know
and before the roast I talked to her and
she didn't remember me
but she was sort of crazy again like
she's just like wildly manic like before
a performance and then she she does it
like perfectly you know I clean it she
was going to do she wanted to do the
producers not the producers but Young
Frankenstein because what's his name
no person's gonna do young for her I
guess Mel Brooks did Young Frankenstein
play Broadway that she wanted to be in
it and she was too old so she won
Dancing with
stars to prove them wrong sure that your
is incredible you know I'm gonna go and
Dancing with the Stars to prove da
Moreira wrong could be on its podcast
just just with the Celebrity Apprentice
yeah I wanna Gilbert to be on it longer
but I realized that the big because I
really liked that show Celebrity
Apprentice
why because I liked Lou Ferrigno because
he said first of all he said he has a
crazy voice because he's deaf and he
hated Lisa Lampanelli getting the border
to go yes I'll tell you this right now
mr. swamp if she was a man I would saw
through the walrus and he gets and then
every episode like his only ideas wife I
was where on the street and dis
reflexing iLike how well behaved
pendulum was yes mr. Trump box about
you're a great guy but I gotta tell you
you're fired the celebrities who they
know that could donate the most money I
couldn't get any [ __ ] money nobody I
can think of one person if you went Sam
Simon was alive you would have called
him yes yes but yes that's the to do it
yeah it's just uh
yeah like when Gilbert was on it cuz yes
obviously like Joan Rivers okay you know
knows a million millionaires you know
yeah that that's why you'd be a good for
being the apprentice no I already do
Kenny Duke you know a poker player so
she knows rich poker player yeah I mean
I love shows where like celebrities are
on yeah like celebrity would gilbert
phone I mean maybe Larry David know he
Howard Stern I don't know
so what all right right
so what's this thing why is our D and
not and Gilbert not on Howard Stern now
he's more PC that you hear something
than how he already said something and
like III don't have satellite yeah I
heard something that all of a sudden
that Stern is more but stern never had
already on after Raya or or Gilbert I
thought either and then then already
made a statement on the show he had
stuttering John on his show this is
something you would have got a kick out
of cuz Ryan Zimmerman said oh no John
was on body
yes startings John had a podcast and he
and I didn't want to do it and Darren
Carter does it and yeah anything to say
you know you like anal like you know
it's like you ever do any no sex acts
pain and you like like stuttering John
yet shows a soul I like I'm a celebrity
get me out of here or it's always
someone like some rappers mother on it
on Celebrity Rehab or you know what
statement did already when when I guess
when a story John was on and he made
they made some statement Howard's my PC
or some but then already felt so bad and
you know just but something Len Howard
was the big man saying when I listen to
him now it seems like he's a completely
different show and that's what I hear
I'm Satya the batter it's just he
doesn't he's becoming like the best
interviewer of all time and he does
these long-form interviews with like
Bill Murray and you know giant stars and
they're like riveting yeah so he doesn't
do the kind of Gilbert kind of stuff
anymore and he likes everybody you know
I mean like he doesn't trash anybody's
either and yeah I don't I don't hear him
with any other I don't hear any other
comedian on the show just you know Benji
and guys that work there right right so
it's probably not how could you have bad
feelings we get over it you know
well norms favorite is Opie and Anthony
just I love how these yeah you know I
you know what
during dirty work Artie and I were like
traveling but this was before I was on
Howard Stern but we were that was their
idea I've had to advertise the movie was
made already do stand-up that's it like
no TV ads oh just you go around the
country roots so anyways we go to one
club and we go to the radio show and the
ladies for everyone which is like Norman
oh you're on Howard Street big fan
Howard Thurman oh yeah I love Howard
Stern is the best because you'll love
these two guys they're jerking off right
now you texted me put the guy at weather
not flappers but where everybody was
doing the crazy dirty stuff when did I
forget what it said oh no it's someone
there's a thing at UCB called the dirty
show the midnight show we just [ __ ]
crazy and one guy took a [ __ ] on stage
you know
yeah the Reverend Bob levy and they go
he gets he gets a girl every no no yeah
because it that was like a big tour you
know because he's famous from Stern Neil
hemorrhoid any travels even was like
guys like big guys like Colin Quinn or
Jim Norton but yeah that's exact it's a
stern line you follow that Stern has
more get used to have more guys like
that but now it's these long interviews
at the Montreal Comedy Festival there
guys from all over so you know they do a
gala they do that this time one gala on
so during the week the comedians are
trying to get noticed and so Tim Allen
was there was right before he broke and
stuff and so he was at their club soda
which is a place of Montreal and a guy
before him took his pants off he had
giant balls we have to rock it up an
[ __ ] like shot a rocket out of his
[ __ ]
so the whole place is just [ __ ] like
it's a huge murmur through the nut
murmur like then the interview Tim how
nobody even hears a bit you know in
today howling goes out but he's
depressed and try to get your to say and
so the next day everybody's talking
about it you know I'm [ __ ] so funny
you know everybody thought um since -
now I'm like Razzles about it and [ __ ]
Tim Allen's like asses going to gala and
he's depressed because his last show so
bad so then Bob Newhart is the host of
the gala but Bob Newhart had just flown
in and just drove to the gals we knew
nothing of this story you know and then
the first thing Bob Newhart comes in to
rehearse and Tim out walks up to anyways
oh hi mr. Newhart's of big honor and he
goes oh hi goes I'm Tim Allen y'all be
blowing a Rakhi on computers well you
know someone told me some things Jamie
from the Laugh Factory says because he
goes I heard that word of mouth and you
put me between a rock and a fireplace a
rock in a fireplace computer now what's
the wind God is doing norm had a big
rivalry this guy you enormous on signing
that live sky Wayne Collins I was flying
I used to go to the laughs action Wayne
Carter would always snub me
knows that comic strip Alliance yeah I
wasn't trying to go talk to him he would
just approach me and then snub me like
but I wasn't putting my hand out too
shaken right so anyways one time we're
on an airplane and he's in he's and so I
say to him the day before this was not
when I was on the show but the Saturday
before it was a Saturday when Chris
Farley did the Chippendale sketch you
know with Patrick Swayze which was like
the best thing on Sara alive in years
you know it was you must have seen that
Phillippe you know I thought when
Patrick Swayze so it's like this instant
classic and there's nothing is funny on
Saturday I have four years everything so
everybody's talking about so I said away
Kotter
did you see a Chris Farley like
personalities funniest thing I ever saw
and he just gets up and goes to the
bathroom and there's wife says I mean
that's just competition what kind of
supplies
we're just Broadcom except sketches yes
yes yes Jo Duvall or of Allah or saliva
yeah Anna Baker no they had uh had some
guy joe tafolla or a Velo
yeah joe DiBona from Sanford oh yeah
well not a useless name on Seinfeld
Ebola so it's the norm show ever gonna
come on - laughs TV they got all these
things I've never that's a new digital
station where they got to carry and Spin
City III got rid of cable to save money
and they got all these great digital
channels with like new arm movies and a
channel they have it on digital movies
anywhere oh I love Noir yeah I love this
Elijah cook jr. they don't have people
like if the you know Elijah cook Jr is
he worked if they had a guy like him now
he'd be
they'd say he should have his own movie
back then you had guys that would just
character actors yeah now got like Paul
Giamatti or fill the lake Philip Seymour
Hoffman they go he's gotta have his own
movie oh yeah he was always like a
second guy you gave me the Orson Welles
movie I forgot which one and I forgot
what it's called Eastern evil yes not
only to go to Mexico the one where the
one with the mirrors or something oh
yeah no yes yes yes yes no big big noir
guy well is sterling Hayden Hayden yeah
Oh God he would send oh oh great
character actors now sterling here's
another great a character actor was
Robert Ryan yes well I got introduced to
those guys in the Dirty Dozen first I
didn't know they had careers oh that
Robert Mitchum is my favorite coolest
guy yeah like Robert Mitchum in the one
with Kirk Douglas you know I got so into
no pastor I get [ __ ] to go to our
channel it's on digital I'll find it but
it's all yeah yeah no no yeah it's one
of those digital channels but I mean
Roku it's unlike Apple TV you know you
know Tom Kenny who loves noir zwi go to
a place he's obsessed with dragnet with
Jack Webb so we go to this bar we go I
love drag that I haven't done I love how
everybody just reads off cards yes but I
love the even the Imperius they just
stand there yes I love dragnet and Tom
Kenny loves this there's a barn well
sure the a broom T where the dragged
Jack Webb had his own table and yeah
yeah and I love noir I want to stop
getting into Murder She Wrote cuz I
heard
all new our guys were there living life
you know I wanted so that about watching
those shows like Matlock immersion yes
because of all the old stars like Claude
Akins will show up or something like
that you know or yeah Fred MacMurray I
knew him growing up my three sons I
didn't know he was a bad guy in some of
these no well yeah yeah whatever that's
called double indemnity oh man we've got
a Philippe you into new ours may be that
but that's probably the best Casablanca
that's a noir sure that characters
actors do they guy with a boat bulgy
eyes oh I love that heavy guy who's that
British guy Green Street or like the sex
symbols back then I don't think we'd
make it they're like Humphrey program Oh
another what's-her-name from Double
Indemnity
yeah he'd be like Gregory Sierra from
Barney Miller's D Buscemi not even Steve
Buscemi yeah he'd be like an ugly guy
playing yeah I love that I love movies
about old Hollywood what was the thing
the naked face no no something with
Bogart oh I can't think of the name but
he he was a screenwriter I love stuff
about old Hollywood knows noir Maltese
Falcon no but there was another one yeah
treasure mods oh no no I can't think of
it but I love all that stuff well this
was entertaining amber then get it but
amber took off I think she's a mad I
hope she's not Felipe's grim before to
being you too my wife's a big fan of you
it's uh my wife and our big fans I try
used to like your sports show I remember
of a funny man when you to do the little
video the little pictures when you had
your Sports Show and then you were tired
and Filipe like [ __ ] quickly googling
me now and then you had all you had I
think I fell rock you didn't you're
talking about some boxer then you said
like the great
you said wearing weaken legs no he
Felipe's a big fan and he's to add the
shoulders og did it really I forgot it
was updated it was og killed oh well you
don't know I all right one little every
thing in a sick way you must field sort
not feel sorry for oj but it's so
obvious if he didn't have this other
thing what what what he did should be 9
years you know 30 years armed robbery
but it's like I'm glad he's in prison he
obviously killed the first two but
anyone else if they did that a guy right
community service you're schmuck you
know you came in you know this thing you
can't charge it you can't put a guy in
jail for something you think he did but
it seems like they did that with yeah
he's like all right let's go in and get
my memorabilia but it's yeah well let's
let's get some of that what's that
called Roku money what's a thing of
Sony's change you probably know he's
probably got at least 30 Gary Gulman did
it and from one of his CDs got 30,000
alone they played that how is satellite
all the time always talk comedians
whether they're famous or not if you're
if you know comedy album is being played
somewhere somebody's playing it it's
part of like there's a lot of Latino
comedians and every single mio every
every sing every may they put a bunch of
like you know comedians together and I
totally get your money man oh how about
one thing before we go I got a voicemail
from my mother should I play it yeah
let's see what she has to say
she said get on Stalin exchange bread uh
uh let's see where is it I haven't
called in a week Oh two of them for her
oh no oh no oh no two of them so much
she's nervous unless something happened
oh did you plug it into the this way
here Fred okay nothing case you're right
and she says that nor McDonald [ __ ]
you told me about yeah I'll stop if it's
personal give me a call when you can
bye I just called alright mm alone just
for the and probably more for the
Fantastic Four bit so things you're on
other people's so Thank You norm so much
thank you yeah we'd love that love it
and you know we you know what comes here
he gives out free pot samples the guy
who runs speed retweet okay Benson said
I did we would love you let's set
something up to come in like I said I
would never do I know you did that
Vincent but it's kind of weird like what
happened with me is all right with you
because you were working guy but one
committed people are just starting out
in the business you know okay big smoke
we don't know what happened with me is
like I'm stoned out of my mind laughing
and he's rolling his eyes go we have
prepared segments here mister
interrupter it's like I'm an [ __ ] for
like laughing at it hard I get a warning
with him though I was annoying I talk
too much
but but yeah he would interrupt but he
would like just go Fred here is inter
not part of the program and I'm thinking
that's I just that's like if I have a
podcast where we we wrote we spin around
and get did you know we have to spin
round around and I'm mad too they're
dizzy you know some guys won't go on
this come on the show I guess they they
don't want people to know they smoke
weed like Norma Dallas most we tweeted
me all the time I'm like what the [ __ ]
first of all if I didn't want anyone to
know why are you saying secondly I've
only met you once
well Janeane Garofalo thirty years
but well it's funny because I watched
his I thought I watched his super high
me you know and I thought well this is
you know because he does smokes weed
every day for years of it I thought well
this guy will really be able to handle
his weed wrong
he's like a Miss advertisement for weed
you know I mean like his whole face
becomes a weird mask
I got I got a clip of a guy norm wanted
a plug
Brian Keller and right Mike Christian
all right uh plug Mike Allen and and
this will go up and all right no I got a
clip yeah we'll put up a clips and Oh on
the website and I'll send you the guy
that screams he's Christian conservative
and [ __ ] you if you don't like it I
think Philippe thank you for having an
even amongst Christians it's very
embarrassing to talk about Christianity
well you showing how ball tonight in a
Christian family I mean no it was never
ever mentioned you'd go on Sunday you'd
meet your neighbors you come home if
anyone ever like said the word Jesus
Christ it would just be the most
embarrassing [ __ ] thing ever
you know I mean let alone a guy talking
about a lot of stage now whenever watch
Bill Maher I watch it picturing you
watching it and getting annoyed they had
a contest to win
you could win and meet Bill Maher like
who would who you could be a fan and
like what he says what God this like I
want to meet let's hang out with that
was surprised to get to hang out with no
Mario alright when I add my sitcom mad
win a date with norm and this is Bruce
Alfred the idea you know any idea that
would try to you know he convinced me
that this would keep the show on I'm
going to win with people pissing and
you're talking about the head writer of
my show we're going to up front and he's
like I got an idea and like what is it
he goes when people are kissing in the
year
your voice making jokes um I call my dad
what I'm the urinal people are pissing
on me yeah he's like can we record you
say stop just enough so I did it was so
[ __ ] humiliating and and then ever
there's a win a date with norm so I'm
like ah [ __ ] what if it's a psycho who
else would want a date not like I'm a
sex symbol or something so uh you know
I'll just pick a married woman you know
that way
she won't be a psycho and then I pick
her and then she shows up and she she
just got divorced so my date is a
bowling alley you know we go bowling
it's me the entire cast and crew of the
show to protect me and then this woman
and then her brother who is like a
sulking Fanning guy of dangerous-looking
character and he would even he sidled up
to me and halfway through guys I thought
I'd [ __ ] hate you but you're all
right I really like boys are getting
nice by the her younger brother and then
she kept going of she was and she turned
out she was like oh and she kept going
friends Chris Isaak showing up never
liked what she associated delusion that
Chris Isaak was actually coming catchy
wanted to date was so she's not been fed
well enough ha ha
well you know know what you want to do
when it does when we act out in the war
scene did you see the one I did with
Fred Willard and David Koechner I sent
to that noir I'll send it again we did
like like in the work kind of thing and
I'll send it to you where I'm in
tomorrow I'll do one of them what that
man Thank You Felipe is it okay that
Norm took over sort of and yeah you take
over who the guest to man Felipe is the
greatest guy actually I turned down a
job for Philippe II think I was supposed
to open for you in uh Austin but I got
cancelled but it's okay yeah I thought
they'd love it
Las Vegas Nevada you're nice yeah
let's do it let's do it please all right
guys thank you so much nothing than
Goodman in your normal well that was the
longest one we did do we have bad it did
yeah we have also the other comedian as
Berger on relief that was the crazy
longest one but it that's right norm
stuff I'm Mike yeah yeah man amazing
grass burger I would know his very
comedian was that guy hamburger from Def
Jam yeah yeah hamburger Oh Philippe
thanks for being a good sport I'm gonna
mention my gigs are you gonna air this
Friday or next Friday next Friday
what's up full view listen to me right
now Felipe Esparza I also have a webapp
our podcast it's called what's up food
and a web series there Fred's been on
also so leg Felipe thank you for this
thank you for everything I got the
podcast cuz you you're a great guy I'm
gonna run to the bathroom
me too so still listening please
subscribe please rate it please um what
else I have to do rate review on I made
in the way to review you know tell
everyone and this is the one with norm
and Felipe and amber and thank you so
much Yemen all things comedy by the
birch thank you Mike I was crazy huh
those crazy
what's up food this is Felipe as far as
on the water food podcast check out my
new web series I created for uglies
conrol it's called the shop starts
Monday October 5th it's about two guys
who work at a marijuana dispensary new
episodes come out every Monday at noon
pacific time watch at youtube.com slash
atc
you
Oh